okay so this is called found horror
games 11 and apparently it's game 1 I
don't know why it's called found horror
games 11 and this is game 1 that doesn't
make a lot of sense but we're gonna find
out I think it's like one of the I think
it's an RPG maker a style [ __ ] game
which I haven't played in ages I don't
think it's very long but then again I
don't really know okay
wise to move Zn or space to interact
confirm escape queue to cancel open
inventory okay got it
I've forgotten everything ooh this adult
wait adult content warming this is does
go home aka a study gamer and welcome to
my camera gory game 11 dot X camera hey
who did that what's one of you did that
it's so scary oh yeah okay we're back
let me just double-check that it's
actually going to be not DIF up in the
dick alright whatever we're gonna get
into this ignoring the camera it should
be fine if it turns off again then I'm
gonna have to turn it off of them we're
gonna have a nice little camera list
let's play while it charges up its
battery or I run downstairs and grab
another battery for it but it shouldn't
need another battery I switch cameras
recently I had my a 9 up here which was
a total waste but now I've gotten a 7 3
up there which is also a waste but it
looks real good but it's not as good as
my a 9
Oh start doing it yeah it's focus also
isn't as good like the autofocus system
is is just a bit slower it's not quite
as snappy I don't like it but an a 9
would be like super overkill for a
webcam even though it works great
alright this is found horror games 11
taking the time to buy and play this
game but before we begin I feel I should
explain a few things and setup what you
can expect to experience here okay what
is that what is it what is it this is a
horror game so I recommend playing in
the dark and with the lights off with
headphones
first of all call it a [ __ ] ritual if
you will people have to kind of allow
themselves to be immersed okay if you
say so hang on I'll turn on my lights
I'll turn out the lights
oh I'm good at turning out the lights
okay lights are off
it's buki back there okay spook you
there and I'll keep that one on it's
good rim lighting maybe I can turn this
one off my main one how spoopy are we we
spooked up is this spook tastic we have
maximum spewpa JH alright it's pretty
spooky yeah pretty spooky everybody okay
it's poo it's super spoopy we're as
spooky as we can spook here we go this
game is actually 11 games technically
they are from some old notebooks VHS
tapes a cassette site ruin record stuff
too in the late 90s and early 2000s I
got into game development when I was 10
when a friend named John introduced to
me the game development software at the
time called games factory these days the
more modern version goes by confusion I
think god damn it
it got too spoopy my camera turned off
god [ __ ] why alright well we're going
maximum spewpa chose it can't [ __ ] my
[ __ ] god [ __ ] a duck alright we
needed we just need to get time apparent
actually I'm gonna run down grab another
battery and pop in this bad boy I don't
know why it's do but it's not it should
just charge on its own but it's not so I
don't know what's going on with this
[ __ ] my a 9 never gave me any problems
like this it's [ __ ] [ __ ] lay a
night like I [ __ ] love that you know
what [ __ ] I'm gonna switch out this
[ __ ] camera with the other one
because this one is just just a big old
dick yank in comparison to the a9 cuz
the a7 3 [ __ ] I bought that it was
hard to get to cuz he was like out of
stock everywhere and out all the reviews
like who's great good very
cost-effective care [ __ ] you [ __ ] you a
seven
[ __ ] you and [ __ ] you I'm replacing you
you are a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll be back
I'll be back I'll be back maybe maybe
the ghosts okay you know I wall i'ma
while I'm gone I'm gonna play some
spooky music
like a YouTube's 10 our spooky loop okay
wait hang on no that's that's probably
not scary at all
oh yeah s spoopy that's properly spoopy
alright you know what else is gonna come
up the scariest thing of all scariest
thing you've ever seen a bunch of ads
ooh I can't play ads right now [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] amazing camera [ __ ] there's
nothing but trouble
it's not from start to finish
[Music]
I don't want to [ __ ] duck but you
know [ __ ] duck you know why you can't
even hearing K because the music's too
loud isn't it you can't even hear me
[ __ ] I'm complaining over here get the
subtle nuances of my emotions expressed
you can [ __ ] hear me or not I don't
know [ __ ] this spoopy dark on being
[ __ ] okay
whatever I've not done exposure
no not USB connecting the mass storage
what what what check the connected what
it's ploy it's a power plugin connected
to my inch of power plug what do you
mean check the connected it's a power
plug it's it's literally it's not a
device it's a power plug plug it's not
mass storage it's no it's not it's not
it's not it's a power plug how are you
thinking that a nine I just sing your
praises talking come on there we go okay
we're good we're good
okay I gotta change the exposure
settings god I hope you guys loved this
behind-the-scenes tutorial on how
youtubers suck ass oh I'm not gonna be
able to know because they turned my
[ __ ] light off so I'm not gonna know
what the right god [ __ ] okay so does
this look okay oh I turned it off
autofocus for the off [ __ ] Oh what I
moved it I turned off the auto foot oh
god damn it why don't you work all right
now that should look good that's gonna
look good and it's gonna be perfect
I turned it on auto white balance God
all right we're back in business
time for spewpa ch we're good you ready
for a fun I didn't game right for a fun
game whoo
all right for a fun game see that's much
better on the autofocus much better face
to section look yeah see it pretty good
right you blocked that [ __ ] it's locked
on it really likes my face there didn't
you snap it back Oh better and it knows
me it locks onto me love me the camera
loves me
it looks just the same but man is this
camera better what what were we even all
right this game yeah okay all right
friend named John why do I care scare me
I spent so much time making turkey games
never see the light of day okay we're
good but they weren't fun to make and
when I wasn't making them I was Ryan
ideas and notebooks and recording with
this cheap camera my dad got me for a
previous Christmas I recently remembered
about these projects and went down
memory lane when I found one of my old
notebooks most of them weren't horror
game ideas in fact most were just fan
games as I used to be a huge scaredy cat
ah but I think I was also deep down
interested in horror and dark twisted
things just I was too scared to put the
pieces together to realize it I would
have nightmares of scaring me too much
that [ __ ] would stick with me
why is this the preface for this I
actually started to gain inspired by my
dreams though and eventually I stopped
finding them scary and more
inspirational I guess okay all right
that's cool and all so scare me come on
scare me scare me I'm here do it please
scare me I guess I kind of just started
venting this part of me I wasn't even
really a
era or maybe purposely ignored into
these ideas I would have anyways I don't
want to keep you guys waiting too long
for the first game so we'll get right
into it when I start I started this
dream 24 minutes ago
turn my light off right that's what I
was doing ya gotta make it spoopy let's
go for the spoop spook me swoop me hard
okay these games are recreations not the
original games I made never finished I
made a few changes to them such as
replacing copyrighted content and such
to make it second sell this I also
thought it might be fun to make this
into a community effort so the next game
will only be unlocked for everyone once
some conditions are met in the game
harker there is a red circle a blue
triangle and a yellow square hidden in
each game you often have to do something
special to make these colored shapes
appear
all right when you find them and if no
one else has found them post them in the
steam community discussion board because
once I see that the red circle blue
triangle and yellow square have all been
found in the previous game
I will then unlock the next game just
take a screen cap or a video for proven
post it in some cases they'll also ask
for a phrase it says when you examine
them why why I mean I get it that's kind
of a clever idea but I just I didn't
look I wanted to I'm doing a nice long
happy stream I'm just I'm trying to I'm
trying to just play game can I play the
game can I just play the game without
this meta thing I didn't I didn't sign
up for it I didn't sign up for it I
didn't I didn't sign up for this I
signed up for a nice spoopy experience
there's 11 games in total and they'll be
unlocked one by one as the colored
shapes are found so we're all in
kindergarten and we have to find color
shapes I think that's about it well also
you can resize the window by clicking
and dragging the sides of the screen f12
to take a steam screenshot and f4 to
switch between the windowed and
full-screen mode ok with all that start
with Game one let's get started alright
let's do this guy's
come on now let's go let's go let's go
oh [ __ ] hi I'm so [ __ ] bored right
now watch your language
alright so what are we doing here why
are we doing it and who are we doing it
- oh it's might even my obvious ah [ __ ]
don't be loud like that Jesus all right
I think that's is that good audience oh
god it froze this is such a drag
what's the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] is it cuz I hate fullscreen
it's cuz I hit that it's [ __ ] frozen
shop you're so loud okay we're gonna do
guys you're good
[Music]
it's gone it's fine it's fine I'm
turning my light back on it's totally
fine
why are you downloading at 54 megabytes
per second what the [ __ ] are you doing
this game that I just why what did you
just download my camera's freezing now
what the [ __ ] are you doing game
watering wanted to play game I just want
to play again
I'm gonna load the game back up I'm
gonna load it and it's gonna work there
it is there it is there it is
I'm leaving the light on cuz I don't
want it I don't want the spoop anymore
I don't want the spoop here we go watch
your skip I want to skip it please just
pretty please I just you know mm let me
think ah nope game 1 attendant here we
go it's time also also it said that
there might be nudity in this game it
said adult content so I might get banned
just a fair warning might happen just so
you know might happen I might get banned
so here we go all right well okay
chores no oh my god that character is
not pleasant an empty trash can
some items to tempt customers
last-second purchase it's the cash
register
I really shouldn't mess around with this
alright there's some supplies nothing
particularly important read note sure
inna if you have any spare time on your
shift tonight could you mop up the mess
the guy before you left I don't know why
he was masturbating in the bathroom
stall he quit last second he left some
puddles Abra
I didn't know that I would be dead on
with the whole masturbating thing but
apparently I was absolutely right so
100% he was jerking it everywhere all
over the place
aisle 7 aisle 8 aisle 9 even aisle 10
it's crazy this man he's unstoppable
anyway go clean up those puddles all
right I think there's like six bubbles
he was so angry left puddles I think
there's like six bottles around you can
take mop from the storage closet you
don't need to do this trust me it's not
good idea to do this don't do it you'd
have to be freaked to want to do this
what if you want to do it it the bigger
it'd help if you did but I would
understand literally no human would want
to do this but if you're into that sort
of thing go get them up from the
gauntlet okay all right I got the mop
from the closet it's a landline phone
for the station no one usually calls
it's late at night or at all really all
right cool what is this anyway what kind
of business a grocery stores it's a
convenience store or what oh god it's a
bottle all the objects on the shelf are
organized I shouldn't touch anything
these are for customers not me I'm not
hungry enough to buy anything from the
shelves right now bags just for
customers to buy some candy for sale
junk food for those on the road not
healthy but appetizing
[Music]
puddle of murky water sits below your
feet everything looks in order to me
this stuff won't go bad any time soon I
don't have to replace anything a few
slightly healthier options for those
trying to eat better some cashews
gluten-free chips dried fruits oh I'm
probably doing the thing that causes the
triangle to appear and I don't care
about that I'm just God why am I doing
this freezer with some drinks why had a
freezer have drinks in it why would a
freezer have drinks in it stupid
so freezer with some frozen food the
freezer was it that makes sense
donk all right that no food for me
ah puddle sploosh get out of the way
sign I'm busy mmm this is my locker but
there's nothing of interest inside
that's quite some music there the next
couple of days off but honestly I wish I
could work more they're giving me less
and less hours you were complaining
about being here
well there's a little odd tripped over
traffic cones bit scratched up okay this
place continues to decay I don't know
why we even try at this point this town
is so far from any major roads or
destinations that no one comes around
these parts anymore not since the mining
industry fell under at least and no one
in this hick town cares about theater
that's for damn sure
we stopped putting on plays months ago
and no one even bat an eyelid
it's almost impressive how much no one
cares around here more people keep
moving out places continue to close down
the government keeps trying to buy out
the land and evict us
we're the ones that let the town rot
away watched as all that it's avenues
closed down yet some stubbornly stay
here like they're damn proud of the
place but you can't seem to care about
anything except their own piece of the
pie I've always wanted to be an actor
but this place if God you were as
expedition 'el as the guy in the
beginning I just how is this all fitting
into one piece of paper how did you fit
all this into one piece of paper but
this place is a dead end for my career
why didn't you write your life story on
this piece of paper on a bench I don't
know why I even had any face in it I
guess you can consider this my
resignation notice I could just leave
and I don't think anyone here would care
notice thanks for wasting my [ __ ]
time miles Jeremy Oh
a couple of old bins a pristine flower
gently sways in the wind it's a bit
miraculous that it can even grow here
power generators functioning as intended
okay alright so there's gotta be
something here in storage right this is
the storage closet but appears to be
locked there should be key for if
somewhere so it's got to be somewhere
here right the coat rack it's gotta be
here right I'm giving this the benefit
of the doubt snore outdated computer I
don't have the password however
miscellaneous trash probably in these
lockers right Locker is locked nothing
inside this locker so I am just [ __ ] out
of luck how's this [ __ ] all gone bad yet
I'm just gonna leave that unplugged so
you know the boys bathroom is locked I
sort of recall someone misplaced the key
oh yeah
bathroom a bin full of paper towels and
tissue paper sink is clean toilet paper
is all good doesn't need changing doing
okay I don't need to clean it plunger
for emergencies
[Music]
I'm going as fast as I can go I can't
exactly run so I'm just kind of stuck
meandering at a real leisurely pace let
me go out in the front area there's a
doorway over there there's a doorway
over there I can go over there look not
all is lost all may seem like it's lost
but not all is lost I'm I go through
here and here is gonna be the answer
yeah yeah baby okay give me the good
stuff give me the good stuff give me the
good stuff give me that good stuff give
me the good stuff give me the good stuff
hey it's the perfect all right
break out of the game for just a second
I know you were all heavily immersed all
right we're gonna come to an executive
decision here I see you all complaining
about ads and that's fine I get it if an
ad pops in when something cool is
happening in the game that ain't cool so
here's here's the deal I have to play
ads via contractual obligation but I can
choose when to do it
instead of doing it every 15 minutes I
can take ad breaks between games that's
better right
would you guys prefer that all right
time to spin my wheel of yes No
cuz I mean you're saying yeah but here
we go okay you're not gonna spin what
you didn't do what you didn't do nothing
you [ __ ] as all guys fight that I'm I
spent a lot of time on that wheel
Freiberg Oh
do you ding on me we're gonna fix this
[ __ ] thing cuz I [ __ ] just that
easy it should this works right
and oil [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
why are you shut up you shut the [ __ ] up
your shot is it because always it
because wait that wouldn't why would
that have any effect to it alright it's
gonna be fine I'm turning off no more
automatic commercials
bing-bam-boom bomb no more right but
then once I'm done with this game
God do a little break which is fine cuz
I'm gonna need a [ __ ] sanity break
after this there we go I know we got the
key I'm just seeing if there's anything
else we need fuel goose why is this one
all jiggly gas prices are really going
up again that's fascinating
why was the key in the bush by the way
anything else here no nothing up this
way is that a triangle yeah one of them
square circles cellar door shut tight
with a gnarly-looking lock
gnarly-looking lock i don't even have
the energy to try to make a joke right
now some oxygen tank for tires no that
don't just no see this that's a bit of
sweat that's a bit of sweat not from a
heat it's actually quite cool in here
that's a bead of sweat from stress
that's stress sweat stress what and also
lesson number two you don't fill up
tyres with oxygen
definitely not pure oxygen
that just sounds bad on all accounts
okay
just want to be very clear about that
you can fill them up with regular ol air
cuz uh
that ain't flammable okay we're gonna
get this mop because that's what we set
out to do from the very GetGo of this
weekend we came here to get him up
and we're gonna get him up like this BAM
boom
all right mop obtained mop obtained mop
a bucket
don't I need that for the mop it needs
to go out but I don't want to deal with
it right now why not it's a balk with a
five digit combination on it mess with
it mess with it what in number should I
pin put first four it's one five three
six
fascinatingly it wasn't the combination
I got the mop puddle that's not a mop
sound I want to be very clear that is
there gonna be one oh no there's gonna
be like a puddle hey I got a mop I have
to mop I don't know why he made a puddle
in the girls bathroom but well yeah mop
it mop it there we go
mop it flop flop the mop out here we go
Colin is late in that who would be that
all you have to say
hello who is this
threaten that is none of your damn
business now who is this it's not a
threat it's not a threat it's not a
threat if you don't cut the crap there
we go goddamn creep I'm going to call
the cops there we go no seriously dude
you're creeping me the hell out if you
don't stop I'm really gonna call the
cops
yeah I might yeah I might notice that
yeah I feel like I'd notice that I mean
there's so many naked blood-covered men
here
I just couldn't possibly pick you out
from the crowd say a police lineup they
bring out six naked blood-covered men
I'm just like oh I don't know none of
them are very distinct to me no yeah I
feel like I might yeah I feel like I
might notice that yeah I feel like I I
feel like I'm right
Jesus some people are messed up in the
head that's when you would call the
police you know all those threats that I
made somebody get a wee woo up in here
because we're about to weave our way
back to jail baby how about you call the
police
well the phone's not working
oh oh oh go outside that's apparently
not all right back to mopping lot of
duty duty today oh yeah that was a lock
I think the last puddle has got to be in
there yeah so it's nothing ain't going
right here okay now we're getting into
the thick of this now the game's
starting to get some kind of credibility
here this is why we turned out the
lights here this is why we wanted to
keep it dark and spoopy because we
wanted the option of letting us get
immersed in this it's just off to a
little little rough start but that's
okay fine I can go
so this is the highway huh it is like a
forest here I can't go any farther whoo
what the hell why can't I go this far
what purpose does this serve why can I
just run away I guess oh okay all right
I'm here sometimes she's just gonna mop
up the highway
wait wait on second hair hang on I like
the way the shadow works it is a 2-d
game but they have a shadow here that's
kind of cool
but wait a minute did I just cycle
around in a big old cycle so what
happened here so I can never leave all
right I'm gonna go back in anyway
because this doesn't seem like there's
anything on the highway here that I need
to know about mm-hmm weird though a
little peculiar a little odd I will
admit I think down here that I might
need I doubt that both keys would be out
here so it's gotta be something in like
the back yard right maybe it's one like
it maybe it's one of those games that
didn't expect me to explore that deeply
before anything else but I don't know
coming out here to the front would have
been really difficult have like how
would I have found this to be perfectly
honest if I if I wasn't just absolutely
anal retentive and decided to check
every single possible at like area of
this first I wouldn't have found that
also why am I so slow I don't know where
this last puddle is and I don't have a
key
last puddle is outside on the right side
of the parking lot Thank You mysterious
stranger thank you so much oh you're
just the best okay well I wished I would
have seen it but okay outside to the
right of the parking lot okay
[Music]
not so sure about that one with the
[ __ ] so and I'm just skipping through
as given their due pika did he wait
[ __ ] what wait was that actually the
end of it
I thought I just died any one of two
abducted unlock no shoes no shorts
costume which can be changed at eanes
Locker
what so I'm loading the game back up
okay so it unlocked a no shirt shoes
thing so what I want to know what I want
to know is is that the thing that's
gonna get my channel banned because at
this point I think that if I just get
banned incredibly I think that'll be
fine right that'll be a hundred percent
fine so all I got to do so I gotta go do
that and then it'll be like then I'll
then my channel will be banned and then
I won't have to worry about trying to be
a professional streamer anymore
I won't have to worry about making
videos doing nothing I won't have to
worry about any of that but what I'm
gonna do before that
imma go outside and we get that puddle
and then you know what you know what I'm
talking about
that's all gonna be good
where was the puddle was there no puddle
over here
did someone lie to me that there was a
bottle over here just so that I would
get jumpscared this is not a puddle I'm
gonna go get my channel man I'm like I'm
gonna just get bad I'm just gonna go I'm
just gonna get bad you know I just want
to get banned I'm just kind of Converse
can't get bad here we go
yep change costume well splish Splash I
guess what the [ __ ] is this nothing
what is this this is banning me
oh no touchy would cease not could see
would cease what the [ __ ] what kind of
unlockable [ __ ] is this
she's normal no I'm fine as I am of
course I'm free so is the phone not
gonna ring is that ringing I can't go in
both bathrooms cuz I don't have a key
maybe the back of these would reveal a
secret' thought it does not I recall
well you said you recall someone you
recall someone miss placing it recently
that's what you said or we're gonna say
Oh someone said gas price equals box
code that's a good point
gas prices ah so we got a three four
five nine ten but there was no nine in
the possibility so it all right so it
must be three four five three five
that's the only thing that's the only
thing that could possibly because there
was no eight nine ten so it must be
three four five three five okay I mess
with it three four five three five
dammit
it wasn't the combination well I'm
persistent enough I'm gonna go to the
community hub unlock storage solved the
box by peeking through the hole in the
main room and Club what peeking through
the hole in the main room oh there's a
hole in the wall whoa
so it's two five one three five two five
one three five is that what it is two
five one three five two five one three
five is that it two five one three five
as you can see I'm just riveted by this
two five one pretty
all right cleaned all six pots got
pliers where's the sixth spot I'm
looking at all the lists of things to do
for this I'm not gonna do them there's a
lot of tasks that's necessary to do this
I'm just gonna get on this phone I'm
gonna get murdered that's all there is
to it I'm just gonna go I'm gonna get
murdered cuz that's all I care about
right now I just want to get murdered I
want to get murdered and that's all
there is
yeah I took my pants off
yeah it was a bad choice on my part I'm
going to question you speak up please
what is it that sounds oh yeah I know
what that sounds like
almost farm-raised like that's exactly
the same voice as this like through the
phone just bar like it but it's his dick
so it's like ah yeah I'm a foreign my
penal anyway so yeah I'm gonna go get
murdered don't go get murdered now
murder money please
shouldn't I be dead shouldn't shouldn't
I be shouldn't I be dead shouldn't I be
dead oh whoa
this is different Stransky here hooked
key what that wouldn't be to the
bathroom would it goddamn now I'm
finding [ __ ] I don't want to find she
don't want to die
I'd also I don't know why her walk is so
weird I usually that's something that
I've kind of just blacked it out cuz
honestly I have no idea and it's even
weirder without shoes makes no sense but
here I am maybe it's to this cellar door
is there someone else here oh please
playing a dumb prank on me this has gone
way too far
he's gone way too far I agree out of
here but of course I own her car and my
phone is dead I can't call anyone to
pick me up
hey pony turd stay calm I know you just
have to get through the rest of your
shaft and then Carlo will come and pick
you up
okay I just have to make it to the end
of my shift
all right Oh someone's a knockin yeah
let me look at the key work day ah let's
go down to our DeMott who are those
spines oh I see a key that's good I'm
gonna get dad got the bathroom key
pick up key locker key ah that's not
what I wanted
all right in the bathroom key I've
always wanted to see the inside of a
men's bathroom
[Music]
inah darling I know whatever I don't
care
huggers locked well good thing I've got
one of these what's in there the boy
bathroom key I'm going to boy bathroom
yeah it's gonna be awesome
I'm gonna have so much fun I didn't want
to do that I just wanted to die
it's my die get my channel banned for
all right okay for whatever man the sink
is clean there's no puddle in here if
the toilet seat up and made a mess I
don't wanna clean this up oh okay
not dealing with that okay hope it was
all good doesn't need changing four four
four four four four four four wigglers
four four
for okay whatever it's Joe he's dumb am
I gonna die yet please just end it in my
pain what did I come in here for there's
literally no reason to come in here why
did I come in here before all right I
know the secret now I know the secret
for for you see for the secret is you
take the four and you understand
everything that we've talked about
before you got to take the the the the
the the the the bathroom was the the
alternate choice from the girls bathroom
it's not my first choice it's the
alternate choice so remember that all
I'm looking for puddles on the floor and
for all at for bang boom I I win wow I
did I I
[Applause]
[Music]